travel chaos across europe thousands of
flights cancelled mountains have lost
luggage and soaring prices but what is
causing all this can it be solved and
what does it mean for the travel
industry this is inside store
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the programme i'm
bernard smith
overcrowded airports council flights
expensive tickets welcome to the summer
holiday season in the northern
hemisphere airlines have been forced to
cancel thousands of flights due to
strike action staff shortages and
weather
cues of passengers snaking through some
european airports are a familiar sight
some airlines are advising people to
turn up for check-in four to five hours
early passenger volumes are at almost
pre-pandemic levels but staffing isn't
airlines and airports are struggling to
re-hire people they laid off during the
height of the pandemic leaving workers
in a strong position to bargain for
better pay and working conditions so
some airports have told airlines to cut
the number of seats they're selling
they've been delays from the americas to
australia but it's passengers traveling
to and from major european airports who
are enduring the worst of the chaos
shippol airport in amsterdam is one of
the airport's hardest hit more than half
its flights have been delayed and
hundreds cancelled in july so far
london's heathrow airport has decided to
cap the number of departing passengers
to a hundred thousand a day to try to
minimize delays
airport workers are also striking in the
german cities of hamburg and frankfurt
the german government is fast-tracking
visas for workers from turkey to bridge
the gap
travel delays caused by strikes are also
hitting spain france belgium denmark
norway and sweden
we spoke with willie walsh the director
general of the international air
transport association he says it's the
managers of the airports not the
airlines who are to blame
it's a huge disappointment to the
industry that airports are restricting
the amount of flights that can be
operated or the number of passengers
that can travel through the airport uh
you know it's really disappointing
because airlines want to maximize the
the benefit of this recovery given the
financial
damage that has been done during the
last two years but i think from a
consumer point of view it's very
important that we can give
certainty to customers that their
flights will be operating and i think
these measures while deeply regrettable
will be able to provide that certainty
[Music]
let's bring in our guests in london is
david learmout he's an aviation analyst
and consulting editor for flight global
in portland in the united states is
susan soybert she's a national
geographic travel photographer she
travels extensively for the national
geographic expedition program and
joining us from the farnborough air show
in the uk is alex macharis an aviation
consultant and author of aviation
briefing welcome to you all
uh david i'll start with you easy
question whose fault is all this why are
we queuing forever and missing uh having
our flights cancelled at the last minute
uh i think you could say the fault is uh
with covid
firmly itself and what kovid did to the
industry the
the industry uh lost um billions of
dollars um over that period
it was a long period never has there
been such an extended shutdown of of uh
this industry in fact i'm not sure about
any other industry now during that time
a whole load of changes happened they
had to either furlough or even
lay off
lots of employees
and the big problem is that when they
tried to take them back on again when
demand ramped up and the airlines
started trying to supply it
a lot of people decided they didn't want
to come back
alex
airlines blame the airports airports are
blaming the airlines for putting on too
many seats who's to blame
it's definitely a blame game that's the
consensus and of course you know we
everything does lead back to covid if
you follow the trail but also it's the
decisions that were made in the pandemic
that really are key in knowing how
different aviation markets ultimately
ended up
two and a half years later and in what
state airlines were in also two and a
half years later and i say that because
while the
same storm has ultimately taken hold of
the entire aviation sector not every
airport airline and third party company
were in the same boat many have been
able to kind of withstand the storm with
better financing with
with fewer redundancies leaving them in
a better
fit state now that air travel recovery
is well underway others not so lucky
such as the uk whose aviation market
suffered the worst of all of europe and
of course that had an impact on the
redundancies that then followed
susan you've probably spent most of your
life in queues at airports how has
post-pandemic travel panned out for for
you a frequent
traveler um i've really been trying to
um
play it a little bit like a poker game
really
because there's so much uncertainty
there's a lot of conflicting news
reports
so i was always booking my flights well
in advance i always made sure to have
plenty of time in between my connecting
flights i tried to make my flights as
long haul as possible because here in
the us the pattern that seemed to emerge
as the airline started to function once
more
were that the shorter haul flights were
the ones that were being most frequently
canceled so it was sort of a strategic
move to try to um
you know be able to get to some place on
time which
is a job requirement of mine i did have
my luggage lost for the first time ever
um and that was uh unfortunate
but um you know given all things
considered i feel very fortunate to uh
to have been able to
use my experience in order to get from
point a to point b without very much
hassle could you get your bags back in
the end
i actually did yes finally they they
they just uh spent
eight days in charles de gaulle airport
well they'll speak fluent french then uh
david heathrow's decision to cap
passengers at 10 000 a day very
controversial and has been pushed back
emirates although emirates has now
agreed to deal with heathrow
other airlines other airports have tried
similar is that a pattern you're going
to see other other other airlines also
trying to adopt
yeah i think this is a very interesting
little
confrontation heathrow made its
announcement and said look this is what
with the resources we have the people we
have
this is what we can actually supply
so please don't ask for more than that
and plan your flights and your your
passenger loads uh according to what we
can actually deliver you uh emirates was
the first to shout you know
that this was far too painful they
really didn't want to do it and then
etihad wasn't very far behind but
but shortly they obviously sat down in
around a desk i didn't see this
happening but because um
about
about 24 hours later um a truce was
observed and um the airlines had come to
the conclusion there was no no point in
demanding more than heathrow was
honestly able to supply
and alex uh frankfurt also wants to
reduce the flights uh coming in and now
and lufthansa has agreed with that
apparently schiphol has a similar limit
on passenger numbers
will you see other airlines will we see
other airports doing the same other busy
airports
we will because we haven't yet hit that
that real peak of the summer season and
that is when really the students and the
pupils kind of break up for that
extended summer break and that's going
to have a surge in demand meet what is a
sector that is incredibly short of staff
and that's when that disruption occurs
that's when the queues are formed that's
when we see all of this footage from
around the world but mostly in europe
with with ultimately passengers facing
immense disruption as travel rebounds
and and i think that's what we have to
keep in mind things will smoothen out
from mid-september onwards but it really
is just the state of the air travel
sector right now and all roads lead to
staffing levels
uh alex so does that mean the end of
this summer ritual for some of looking
for those last minute flight bargains is
that is bargains is that something
you're not going to be able to do this
year
well there is there are still deals to
be found of course especially with
budget carriers and short haul but if
we're talking in a more kind of
long-term visionary way we know that the
cost of air travel is going to increase
not least because of the impacts of the
oil price the impacts and uncertainties
of the war in ukraine and so on so there
are all other factors that aviation is
inherently exposed to because if you
think back before the pandemic we we had
periods of air travel disruption and
none of it was pandemic related and and
not very very much of it either was a
were staffing levels related so you know
air travel faces this daily challenge
from so many different external factors
but but as i say the expectation is that
things will smoothen out over the
northern hemisphere autumn and winter
but of course there are other fears such
as a looming recession and and the
uncertainties as i said over ukraine so
only time will tell
david how much
oil prices particularly affecting the
price of our tickets i know some
airlines have hedged on oil prices but
what effect is that having
well oil prices are having a big effect
they always do on airline fares but the
the other thing which is
which is definitely going to have an
effect is
when the airlines and the airports are
hiring or rehiring staff that they laid
off before or trying to tempt new ones
an awful lot of the jobs will have to be
better paid than they were before i mean
it's very easy to write off baggage
handlers as as being sort of humble
creatures at the bottom end of the food
chain but they are incredibly important
and if they reckoned having time to
think about it over the the covid
pandemic that they really didn't have a
job that was worth going into
a lot of them decided they'd do
something else which was better paid so
it's not just fuel prices the airlines
are going to have to pay more for people
especially those in humble jobs which
nowadays the prices being what they are
includes cabin crew and we'll come back
to that staffing issue in a second but
susan i wanted to ask you in in terms of
the cost of flying which must factor
into your budgets for your trips how
what sort of impact is it having on you
have you really noticed a change in the
cost of travel
i have i have noticed a change um
however it's it hasn't been
as substantial as i was sort of
reckoning that it would be um
i've always had to i mean it's just a
company policy that we fly economy um
and so
part of
of the game that i play with the
airlines is trying to figure out ways um
you don't maybe spend just a couple of
extra hundred dollars uh and again
because i i can sort of i can have that
discretionary decision um i might get
one sort of tiny bump up in class and
therefore be able to carry on an extra
bag or be able to choose my seat and
thing and that again will
make me able to get on that flight if it
happens to be overbooked
because i haven't bought the very uh
bargain fair
um it but yes you've there has
definitely been a price increase and it
it was very pronounced on my last flight
back from from france to portland i
bought i had to go to france twice
during the month of june the first
uh ticket was about a thousand dollars
less expensive than the second ticket
even though they were
identical roots so alex is for travelers
like susan for all travelers are they
are the airlines now the ones that are
holding the power of the consumers of
the ones that are having to pay more for
their tickets whereas once upon a time
there was a lot more competition but
pre-pandemic
well there is still competition out
there one of the most remarkable things
of the of the pandemic and of this
immediate aftermath is that actually we
didn't really lose many airlines not not
nearly as many as that were initially
predicted when kobit
was first about and that is because of
the government relief packages and the
financial state aid that went into
supporting these carriers so competition
is still definitely there but that price
increase is probably more likely to do
with the
gradual moving into the summer peak and
that's where we see those kind of key
differences and of course as i said kind
of longer term we know that the cost of
air travel will increase that's
happening in parallel to a cost of
living crisis to a fluctuating but
mostly high oil price and so on and alex
david touched before on the on the
issues of staffing at airport ship all
one of the world's busiest 58 000 staff
at the moment 10 000 less than before
the pandemic
where have they well where have they
gone how long does it take to recruit
them back and particularly security
staff how do long do they take to get
trained and through the system because
people understand the process
well i wrote a column about this in late
january kind of after speaking to
several airlines and airports it became
very apparent to many in the industry
that the staffing levels were not
anywhere near adequate to deliver what
was the summer 2022 schedule that most
airlines were selling now what we've
seen is we've seen all this disruption
as airlines attempted to deliver a
schedule that was far too ambitious that
was mostly in line with 2019 with that
without anything uh even kind of
adequate in terms of staffing level and
uh and the industry has to really face
this now head-on which it is now but
it's simply too late you know where is
is we're in the summer season now in the
northern hemisphere and that's causing a
problem these staffing levels need we
need to have people either return to
aviation many have left but also we need
to make ultimately many of these jobs
better paid because there are so many
people that you speak to that realize
after being made redundant that actually
they can earn more in a supermarket but
the difference is they don't start at 2
30 in the morning they don't have
disgruntled passengers to deal with when
the airline has a technical reform and
so on and uh and so you know
this is a conversation a hard
conversation that the industry has to
have with itself in order to make it
more attractive to bring those workers
back into the sector this of course has
been complicated by factors such as
brexit of course because we've lost so
many eu nationals here in the uk who
departed in the pandemic many of them a
significant majority working in the
aviation sector david you touched on on
this before airline are airlines waking
up to this fact that their staff that
they need to pay their staff more
there's the brexit effect in the uk
which has compounded the issue of course
there but across europe there's a
staffing crisis
indeed there is a staffing crisis um and
in in the not a low skilled or or
semi-skilled um which is you know a lot
of a lot of what airlines need um you
know security uh at least the ordinary
security workers um cabin crew it's a
semi it's a skilled job actually but it
you know they're rated at semi-skilled
but these people are desperately needed
you cannot get them overnight
and and getting getting baggage handlers
they may not need huge skills there but
they do need security clearance because
they work airside and so if you want to
get somebody back who hasn't been
security cleared it can take months to
to actually get the clearance through
because
so many people are applying that the the
agencies the government agencies that
that check security clearances simply
can't cope with the demand
and susan covey 19 hasn't gone away we
all wish it had but it's still lurking
there what when you're traveling
internationally what are you still
finding you have to do to make sure
you've got everything
you need before you can you're allowed
on a plane because many countries still
have restrictions
i um always try to stay as safe as
possible um my goal is to not get sick
and right now i know more people who
have gotten ill with covid than at any
other point during this entire pandemic
i think that's the result of a
combination of the relaxed masking rules
uh the
i was in france the day that the united
states dropped the requirement for a
24-hour negative test
prior to flying back to the states from
you know international locations
and um and so there's a direct
correlation between dropping the mass
mandates and the testing uh requirements
and the jump up
in
the number of covet cases but also the
fact that it is mutating so quickly i
mean it's um
it's it's being allowed to uh to kind of
go unchecked and we can't keep up with
the vaccinations because of the mutation
so it's a it's a very complicated
situation and i just wear a hospital
grade uh n95 mask at all times and
that's
what you know and try to stay as far
away every single flight i have been on
the last two months has been absolutely
packed for
obvious reasons
um but i knock on would have not um
contracted it i test regularly and uh
doesn't sound so far managed to avoid it
doesn't sound much glamour left in
travel at the moment alex a lot of those
people leaving europe are heading to
further afield heading to the developing
world often uh north africa the
subcontinent of africa asia
those are places dependent on tourism
how are they being affected by these
delays in in europe is it putting people
off going
not really no we are seeing now
thankfully the reopening of those really
restricted markets those markets that
were closed for most of the pandomic in
southeast asia and south asia across the
subcontinent and so on and of course for
those countries that are reliant on
tourism that's good news for them there
is immense pent-up demand one in three
uk households for example who would
ordinarily travel have vouchers that are
valid for this summer that you can be
sure they are definitely using but i i
just want to go back to that previous
point you were making with susan which
is that actually we still have to keep
having this conversation about kobit
because covet is still causing havoc not
just with the public but also with the
staffing levels that are you know the
staff that are able to show up in the
first place we have so many airlines
declaring an unusually high rate of
staff absences all citing covey but
actually it's another conversation that
the aviation sector is not having with
the governments across the world but
probably would be more sensible to which
is that it is in everyone's interest to
keep transmission of this thing low
because we see the moment there is an
uptick be it of omicron these new sub
variants and so on that immediately
translates into staff absences which in
turn causes chaos for the staff that
were able to turn up in the first place
and david sticking with that theme after
the summer rush is over do you think
demand for flights will hold up i mean
we've got we've just talked about
coronavirus we've got war in ukraine
high energy prices our airlines hope
hopeful that they'll keep up demand
after the holidays september onwards
well all that all the signs are um that
that demand is keeping up which is which
is the problem the the airlines can't
supply what's required europe which has
had a particular problem
is still that the airlines are only able
to supply or the air the combination of
the airlines and the airports are only
able to supply at the moment
85 per cent of pre-pandemic
demand and yet the signs are that the
the demand is going to be more than
pre-pandemic and i i really don't see a
reduction coming um below the reductions
the seasonal reductions that you
normally get
i don't see a particular problem with
let's say northern hemisphere winter
i think that the demand will hold up and
the airlines will still i think until
maybe summer next year they'll still
have
uh
you know varying degrees of problem with
meeting the demand so the airlines do
have the whip hand and i don't think
that the cheap bargains are going to be
around very much for you al alex could
it get worse before it gets better
um i think in this initial immediate
period now we're talking kind of late
july i think the message is to expect
even more disruption as that travel
surge will surge as demand really does
increase as i say in line with kind of
the term time breaks but with everything
scheduled to smoothen out from
mid-september onwards and this is
reflected in heathrow statement for
example they've got that cap of 100 000
a day but that's only valid until around
september 12th i think it shows that
most of the sector is on the same page
there
okay well we're slow we're running out
of time but before we go i'd like you're
all frequent travelers so for people
heading to the airports this summer
susan i'll start with you if i can just
a tip on how to manage
manage airports at the moment manage
your travel best what do you do
um i would i would simply try to find
tickets that have maybe a little bit
more perks to them than rather than
risking
saving a a couple of hundred dollars
because if you get delayed
by any
length of time it could have an
incredible domino effect on your entire
trip and also um
just to keep insurance in mind uh it's
uh
it really came to my rescue a couple of
times to buy a policy and they really
aren't that expensive particularly if
you get trip interruption insurance
david that would be my my tip
i i'd go with susan about
about
don't go for the cheapest
you can go for the cheapest that gives
you the right to cancel your ticket so
they do add you know sort of 20 to 30
percent on but that it may well be worth
it and and it's very much easier to
negotiate with the airline afterwards if
you you are on one of the flights that
gets cancelled all right and alex last
bit of advice from you is a frequent
traveler
sure if you're checking in luggage pop
an apple air tag or an other another
brand similar in order to be able to see
your luggage in real time so that you
can track it that helps because bags are
being lost all over the place carry hand
luggage if you can without checking in
and don't arrive to the airport too
early this message being pushed about
arrived to the airport really early
often that doesn't achieve much to three
hours is usually enough because those
desks are often not even open
brilliant thanks to all our guests for
that excellent advice thanks to david
learmount to susan soybert and to alex
macharis
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website aljazeera.com
and for more debate go to our facebook
page that's facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter we are at aj
inside story from me bernard smith and
the whole team here in doha bye for now
[Music]
you